how do you feel about quotas for me i  would say that in some cert  circumstances that a quota  is  necessary okay um just so for  representation purposes okay um don't  you think it's a little like um sexist  or racist  because because it's like almost saying  that these like like if i'm a woman i  can't get the job myself i need the  government to tell them to do it yeah  like and i i think it actually hurts the  people because then people just start to  think you got there because of a quota  rather than your competence it's hard  because yes a quota would just be like  oh i just hired you because you we  needed to meet a quota and that's all  and they didn't look at your jobs that  you've had before and everything and  your qualifications they just look like  oh you're this we we need to check this  box and check this box this person does  it we'll  train them and so in that in those type  of cases yes